the polling station Barbies were fired
up as Australia voted both sides had
hoped for a taste of victory in what's
been one of the country's closest ever
elections but defying all predictions
prime minister Scott Morrison clung to
power with a win for his Liberal Party
led coalition I have always believed in
miracles
[Applause]
I'm standing with the three biggest
miracles in my life here tonight
and tonight we've been delivered another
one
Scott Morrison's victory is being hailed
one of Australia's greatest political
comebacks he campaigned by himself as
his party fell out over policy many
thought bill shortens labour party would
scrape through but the polls got it
wrong and labour lost it is obvious the
Labour will not be able to form the next
government and so in the national
interest a short while ago I called
Scott Morrison to congratulate him there
was upset for the coalition when former
Prime Minister Tony Abbott lost his seat
this election has been unpredictable the
climate change debate has played a part
attracting votes in urban areas but it
was a harder sell in Australia's rural
mining communities surrounded by his
party faithful the celebrations got
underway the polls had written him off
but Scott Morrison proved them wrong
achieving what many thought was
impossible he remains Prime Minister one
paper calling it a political miracle
moribund Alaska